locaux du parlement européen sont en
grande partie vide pendant la phase de
confinement
alors le président sassoli a décidé de
mettre à disposition notamment de locaux
de strasbourg qui vont servir pour
mettre en place un centre de dépistage
contre le coc vide qui sera très utile
de la phase 2 les confinements la mise à
disposition de notre flotte de voitures
de bruxelles qui vont permettre de
transporter les soignants la mise à la
disposition de notre restauration qui va
permettre de fournir 1000 repas par jour
pour les soignants également ainsi que
pour les sans abri notamment qui aiment
recèle 90 donc une solution
ça nous permettra également nous députés
repères de mettre à disposition des
permanences européennes locales comme la
vienne ici à belfort qui vont permettre
d'avoir un accueil téléphonique et par
mail pour répondre à toutes les
questions des concitoyens
voilà ça prouve tout cela que le
parlement européen est au plus proche
des citoyens
et je pense que c'était important que
nous puissions mettre à disposition ses
moyens comme le font d'autres organismes
d'autres personnes pour lutter
efficacement contre le coronavirus